I have no words guard your kidneys let's
go hey river babes I'm your host Leonid
Galera and this is your Sweetwater
Secrets after-show for episode 56 the
dark secret of Harvest House which takes
the cake as the most mind-blowing ly
insane episode we've ever had on
Riverdale Riverdale is broken I'm going
to be unleashing a terrifyingly honest
round of hisses and kisses and then
gifting you with an exclusive montage of
lily Reinhardt cole sprouse and more of
your favorite Riverdale stars revealing
a big secret to me but first
hold on tight and get ready for a
whirlwind of crazy as we recap what the
hell just happened in the blue and gold
breakdown with Betty now fully
infiltrating the farm she discovered a
number of mind-blowing secrets
turns out Edgar has been hypnotizing his
farm ease during their creepy little
sessions and then while there under his
spell he's having other farmers pretend
to be the person they're trying to
communicate with yeah for example in
Betty's first session she thought she
was communicating with her shadow self
Betty but when Betty wore wax in her
ears to block out Edgar's hypnosis she
realized it was poly dressing up his
Betty to try and trick her and plant
dark seeds in her mind you're a killer
just like dad and it's time that you
embrace as if that wasn't weird enough
we had an even bigger what the farm
revelation this week when Betty
discovered that the kids are being
forced to have surgery he transforms our
emotional pain into physical pain so
it's easier to treat in Venice Betty was
understandably confused
but when she lifted up Kevin's shirt and
saw a nasty massive scar it all became
clear it took my freaking kidney turns
out things are way more effed up than we
could have ever imagined Betty
discovered a secret room that's filled
with all these harvested organs and that
the farm is manipulating and deceiving
kids and then cutting out their body
parts and honestly I cannot believe this
is a storyline and I cannot
believe that this is actually happening
shunned and non-believer yeah fine
anyways
Betty managed to finally wake Cheryl up
from her farm II haze by throwing a
beach cooler fooled with a spleen or
whatever in her face and then Cheryl
freaked out and went to rescue Tony from
her procedure they ran like hell and
then Cheryl sacrificed herself so Tony
could escape into the night wearing
nothing but a hospital gown because
fashion now you just sound cuckoo pants
but the worst part of it all is that
Kevin and things physically dragged
Betty into Edgar's clutches and the
episode ended with him
strapping her down and forcing her into
surgery I'm not making this up
as for Jughead well first he went to
stop little Ricky from ascending and
just as I was shocked to realize that we
were actually seeing Foxwoods in the
middle of the day a tribe of psychotic
little boy scouts chased him through the
woods and sure why not what is the
meaning of this while safely in the
bunker he found Ethel hey there she is
who's still completely deluded by the
gargoyle King and is now just
straight-up stealin iconic lines from
other properties and not doing a very
good job of it either Oh Jones you
really hope I'm story short they go off
to find one of her missing lost boys
instead of abandoning him like they
should have and then the black hood
showed up hurt the hell out of my ears
with his stupid hook and then ran around
for a while and Jughead trapped him in
the Magic School Bus from hell
as a reward for his bravery princess
ethylene told Jughead the identity of
the gargoyle King what Jason blossom yep
and a confirm it Jughead dug up Jason
blossoms grave and found an empty casket
because apparently we can't have nice
things
it's vital we keep up appearances as for
Archie well he and Veronica teamed up
with the cops to catch Hiram red-handed
doing something illegal which is like
something he does every day yeah Ronnie
your dad sucks so the brilliant plan
that they came up with was to force
Archie a teenager to challenge Hyrum a
super-ripped adult to an illegal boxing
match while Veronica took illegal bets
on the fight at labahn Nui and then when
the cops showed up and raided the place
Ronny was able to blame it all on her
father Hye won now Hiram's in jail and
since Archie somehow survived another
brutal boxing match he went to confess
his love for Annika which leads us to
this week's rendition as seven seconds
in heaven things were very light this
week and the only real romantic
highlight of the episode was the fact
that Mary Andrews proved to us that
she's not just a regular mom she's a
cool shipper mom personally I think your
end game but in a bizarre twist when
Archie showed up to get his girl it
appeared that she had already been taken
she told Reggie that she wanted to
rekindle their Veggie flame that is what
I said nothing in this scene made any
sense
why has barchi been flirting like crazy
but then the second Veronica gets around
Reggie a guy she already dumped she
picks him is this payback for our Josie
Ronnie none of it matters
whatever things with brainwash Joanie
were sweet but then heartbreaking when
Cheryl sacrificed herself for Tony and
now I have nothing else to say which
leads us into hisses and kisses the
first and biggest hiss I've ever had in
the show is going to Edgar ever never
congratulations Edgar because of the
fact that you are cutting body parts out
of teenagers against their will you're
now worse than Hiram the black hood and
the gargoyle King combined
and speaking of the gargoyle King and if
it really is Jason blossom I'm sending a
hiss to that too none of this makes
sense anymore are you kidding me Kevin
found Jason's dead water bloated corpse
in the Sweetwater River in the pilot how
do you explain that a twin so hisses -
dr. kurtal jr. and his equally
incompetent father because at this point
I don't know who else to blame for the
fact that all the dead people in this
crazy little town aren't actually dead
it's not an easy task tall boy Clifford
blossom sheriff Minetta the list goes on
and on and on and now that Jason blossom
is apparently not actually dead well
this twist that keeps happening over and
over and over again is just lazy at this
point and frustrating and not exciting
to watch anymore don't ever do that
again
and the hisses just keep on coming so
hisses - everything else at the farm
especially - Alison Polly who are trying
to brainwash Betty into thinking that
she's got serial killer tendencies
hiding in her jeans are you talking
about also nice try Polly you're the
psychopath and you could never pull off
any signature style
Betty's ponytail is iconic and beyond
reproach I'm going to give a little kiss
to Veronica's sweet angel voice although
I'm following it up with a big history
of pairing a song with Archie's boxing
matches it doesn't make them more
interesting to watch and it made me very
very angry
switching fully over into kisses kisses
- the fact that Mary Andrews has a
wealth of interesting friends that she's
made in her college days at Sara
Florence and the fact that she seems to
hate Hiram as much as we do after
everything that Hiram has done to you
and to your dad and to this town I'm
gonna watch and after watching this
week's insanely confusing and weird
episode and we try to figure out how the
hell we got to this place
it's Riverdale I want to remind you
reverbs that all of this craziness of
the season was sparked by a game called
Griffins of gargoyles so my last kiss
goes to the stars of Riverdale
for revealing to me that they don't even
understand the rules of this game do you
understand
how G&G works Dorf not entirely it's
confusing it's very confusing and I
don't want to understand the rules of
G&G that's how you get in trouble I
don't understand that I don't understand
Ouija boards I don't understand any of
that I still don't know still trying to
figure it out I have no idea how G&G
works I think I have a pretty good grasp
on it it's all making sense all of this
is becoming clear I think coal had
either played the game or it played
something similar to the game Ursa I
don't know he was explaining things that
I don't really understand how he knew I
remember him trying to tell us what was
what and where it goes because it may be
similar to some others type of like
story is just sort of game
I know it's somewhat like Dungeons &
Dragons based off with that so it's more
of a role-playing improv sort of game
with a game board as kind of a general
outline you know where we go on set they
just kind of put it in front of us and I
rolled the dice and I have no idea and I
haven't looked much into it whole really
knows he actually him and his brother
used to play it or like Dungeons &
Dragons yeah yeah equivalent I thought
it was just game a stupid role-playing
game that's not unlike Dungeons &
Dragons which is much more
improvisational yeah
and that Game Master has much more
improvisation for something like D&D G&G
is as if the game master simply serves
as a middleman to the improv of the
characters and the force that's sort of
doing evil with with the game large so
that that's kind of my understanding of
it is that the game master receives
either some unholy inspiration or the
game is legitimately laid out for them
your mission was unsuccessful everyone
dies and now we're done thank you so
much for bearing with me through this
week's episode and be sure to check back
next week for our live sweet letter
secrets preview for the season 3 finale
of Riverdale chapter 57
Apocalypto okay bye but first if you had
fun with me in this video then please
give me a like and then head on down to
the comments to tell me your thoughts
about this bonkers episode do you think
Jason blossom is actually alive how do
you feel about Cheryl's sacrifice and
the fact that Veronica chose Reggie over
Archie and what do you think is going to
happen in the finale share it all with
me and I'll see you next time for our
last sweetwater secrets episodes of the
season
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]